[Musica]
sono l'amministratore delegato di una
grande azienda che si occupa di motori
industriali e oggi sono qui a parlarvi
di animali
sapete qual è il mio animale preferito
la fenice e sapete qual è quello che mi
piace di meno il dodo sono due animali
che nessuno potrà mai vedere uno estinto
l'altro e mitologico ma rappresentano
due modi diversi di approcciare le
situazioni
il primo non è riuscito ad adattarsi ai
cambiamenti ambientali intorno a sé e ne
è rimasto vittima la scienza infatti
dice che il dodo non era pronto a
competere con altri animali importati
dai coloni europei per le risorse che
aveva sempre avuto a disposizione il
secondo rinasce dalle proprie ceneri
dandosi ogni volta una nuova possibilità
vi starete chiedendo perché io che nella
vita mi occupo di motori vi stia
parlando di animali
allora provo a spiegarmi meglio con un
esempio
tre mesi dopo il mio arrivo alla guida
dell'azienda dove tuttora lavoro che
ricordo è un'azienda che progetta e
realizza motori industriali
scoppia il diesel gate
quando leggi sui giornali il diesel è
morto il tuo mondo fatto di 10 impianti
che producono 1000 ingegneri
che progettano e quasi 9.000 persone che
lavorano sembra veramente destinato a
crollare è per me dal mio punto di vista
insomma non era solo una responsabilità
enorme in termini di business ma anche
nei confronti delle persone e delle loro
famiglie
ognuno nella sua vita si è trovato ad
affrontare un momento critico è in
questi momenti
la domanda è una sola che fare noi
abbiamo colto l'occasione per fare un
salto avanti percorrere strade nuove e
inesplorate lavorando sulla nostra
offerta di proporzioni alternative per
portare il green in ambito industriale
infatti non solo abbiamo studiato e
sviluppato motori industriali a basse
emissioni per un diesel sempre più
pulito ma siamo anche stati i primi a
proporre sul mercato motori a gas
naturale che però avessero le stesse
performance del diesel oltre a lavorare
a soluzioni batterie elettriche fuel
cell a idrogeno
e poi e poi abbiamo realizzato un
concept di mobilità del futuro che
secondo noi possiede ciò che oggi grazie
a un fortunato format televisivo
chiamiamo tutti fattori hicks si tratta
di un concept in moto propulsore
modulare progettato pensando
all'ambiente che può utilizzare fonti
energetiche alternative come bio metano
elettrico e idrogeno e che incorpora
elementi di intelligenza artificiale per
pensare e interagire con il veicolo e il
suo sistema
e l'intelligenza artificiale
ricordiamolo è il tentativo di
riprodurre la capacità che unica
dell'uomo di interpretare il cambiamento
ad ogni modo essendo un concept è un
progetto futuribile l'incarnazione
dell'idea del motore del futuro
ciò che è importante però è che
rappresenta un'idea di innovazione
legata all'utilizzo intensivo e su larga
scala di fonti di energia alternative
una su tutte l'idrogeno
che è leggero
incolore inodore è una resa energetica
elevata e in combustione
genera soltanto acqua e calore insomma è
l'elemento perfetto per una tecnologia
energetica davvero green e in più
risulta comodo perché crea energia
direttamente a bordo del mezzo proprio
come i motori a combustione interna dei
veicoli a cui noi siamo abituati
cosa è successo quindi con il diesel
gate ci siamo trovati mi sono trovata di
fronte a un problema a un grande dilemma
potevamo essere dodo o fenice siamo
stati fenice in questo caso che ho
portato ad esempio l'innovazione
industriale del nostro fattore hicks è
diventata propulsione per lo sviluppo
socio economico ma anche una risposta
concreta alle esigenze del pianeta e di
noi che lo viviamo in termini di
sostenibilità ambientale
oggi stiamo disegnando il futuro anche
in questo momento anche durante questo
evento lo stiamo facendo sono convinta
che il futuro che stiamo vivendo sia
davvero nelle nostre mani lo possiamo
cambiare lo possiamo modellizzare qui in
particolare stiamo parlando di
tecnologie che ci permetteranno di
vincere le sfide della nostra epoca ma
solo se saremo capaci di pensare fuori
dagli schemi di out of the box il mio
motto
perché le difficoltà appaiono
ciclicamente
quindi a mio parere la cosa più
importante è imparare a trasformarle in
opportunità
e solo chi è in grado di interpretare il
futuro e cavalcare la crisi
trasformandole in opportunità può essere
vincente non è questione di energia
parola di einstein
le tecnologie non hanno anima non hanno
valori siamo noi esseri umani a render
le buone o cattive
quando quando parliamo di smart cities
ad esempio parliamo di città che
gestiscono le risorse in modo
intelligente che puntano a diventare
economicamente ed energeticamente
sostenibili e autosufficienti che sono
attente alla qualità della vita e hai
bisogno dei cittadini
ma quando le definiamo città
intelligenti dobbiamo ricordare che
l'intelligenza che citiamo è sempre
quella dell'essere umano
e le tecnologie che ci servono oggi
quelle buone diciamo sono quelle che
rispettano gli esseri umani e che
contemporaneamente possono fare in modo
che la nostra presenza e il nostro
futuro
abbiano una connotazione nuova e più
rispettoso del nostro pianeta
questa secondo me è una sfida davvero
importante
è davvero impegnativa le aziende i
manager oggi devono da un lato
perseguire obiettivi di business
e questa non è una novità e dall'altro
essere socialmente responsabili e
sostenibili
rispettando normative linee guida e
codici etici ed è qui il difficile non
può non deve essere solo una questione
di rispettare le regole per fare bella
figura o per non avere problemi legali
perché tutti abbiamo solo da guadagnare
da comportamenti più virtuosi
ma è indubbio che siano necessarie una
consapevolezza e una responsabilità
condivise che diano vita a una nuova
economia di mercato
competitiva ma in grado di ascoltare e
rispettare l'ambiente in cui opera e
secondo me in questo senso fare sistema
tra pubblico e privato penso
all'università ai centri di ricerca
informazioni alle amministrazioni e agli
enti pubblici sarà fondamentale per
creare tecnologie soluzioni
risposte sempre piu virtuose di fronte
alle difficoltà
come è successo più o meno
volontariamente con la pandemia anche la
pandemia secondo me ci ha insegnato e
può insegnarci o ancora qualcosa o
meglio noi esseri umani possiamo trarne
degli insegnamenti
come dicevo prima trasformando le
difficoltà in opportunità
probabilmente questa crisi ci darà la
possibilità di portare a compimento
ragionamenti e processi di cui già
eravamo a conoscenza ma che ora dobbiamo
necessariamente
accelerare anche grazie al supporto
delle tecnologie buone di cui parlavo
prima
sono queste tecnologie la loro
implementazione
a rappresentare un cambiamento epocale
e ammetto che a farne parte
mi rende particolarmente orgogliosa
all'inizio ho parlato di dodo e fenici
credo che nessuno di fronte alla domanda
diretta abbia dubbi su quale dei due
preferirebbe essere
ma io in più aggiungo che vorrei anche
evitare che ci siano degli altri dodo
altre specie viventi nella sua stessa
situazione
ecco perché la spinta alla rinascita
deve essere sostenibile ed è sempre più
necessario che ci siano azioni mirate e
incisive che ci ricordino e ci preparino
al fatto che avremo sempre la
possibilità di scegliere di essere dodo
o rinascere come la fenice una fenice
che continui a risplendere
grazie